جوا وبحر وبرا تتاهب الدول الاوروبيه
لحمايه خطوط انابيب الغاز خوفا من اي تسرب
او تخريب جديد يهدد اقتصادها خلال فصل
الشتاء تقول صحيفه
البحريه الايطاليه تقوم بدوريات لحمايه
خطوط الانابيب تفاديا لاي خطر محتمل
والمراقبه تتم عبر دوريات مكثفه فوق وتحت
سطح البحر من خلال غواصات وسفن موجهه عن
بعد لاكتشاف اي خلل بخط الانابيب وردع اي
كارثه محتمله السفن الحربيه ايضا تقوم
بفحص خطوط الانابيب تحت الماء وحتى من
الصوت الحفر البحريه وهذا الامر تلجا اليه
معظم الدول الاوروبيه في الوقت الراهن
يقول رئيس اركان الدفاع الايطالي
التسريبات المفاجئه وغير المبرره للغازه
في خطي انابيب النورستريم 1 و2 في بحر
البلطيق كانت بمثابه جرس انذار لاوروبا
ولكن بالنسبه للامن الاوروبي بحر الشمال
هو في الواقع اكثر اهميه من خطوط انابيب
البطيق ولاجل ذلك عززت قوات الناتو وجودها
البحر في بحر الشمال قبل بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا اعتمد الاتحاد الاوروبي على
روسيا بحوالي
45% من وارداته من الغاز الطبيعي بما في
ذلك خطوط الانابيب والغاز الطبيعيه
الحكومات الاوروبيه الى استبدال الغاز
الروسي بواردات من النرويج وجزائر
والولايات المتحده ودول عده اخرى وخمسه
عشر في المئه هي اجماله واردات الاتحاد
الاوروبي من الغازي الروسي في الوقت
الراهن محاسن حضاره
العربيه